moi j'aime vraiment l'application je
trouve ça super pratique
c'est vraiment facile d'utilisation qui
ça ait beaucoup en tant que patiente
julie dubois ce feu traitées pour un
cancer du sein elle utilise opale une
application qui lui donne accès à une
foule d'informations sur sa maladie et
son traitement résultats d'examens
rendez vous mêmes les notes de son
médecin
la première fois qu'on va aller voir un
médecin qui va nous donner les
agnostiques
on retient pas tout parce qu on est
beaucoup dans l'émotion par la suite
quand on a pris le temps peut-être de
plus déjà comme tu peux la nouvelle on
peut aller sur l'application et à les
informer un peu mieux opel a été
développée au centre de santé
universitaire mais gilles à l'initiative
d'une patiente laurie and run décédé en
mai dernier elle trouvait que en tant
que patiente
il lui manquait toute l'information par
rapport à ces soins de santé et on
voulait trouver un moyen de pouvoir
faire ça avec elle de lui donner son
l'information donc au bout de ses doigts
en plus des données personnelles du
patient opel offre beaucoup
d'informations contextualiser chaque
fois que l'on donne des résultats on
essaie de les expliquer donc lorsqu'ils
voient leurs résultats de laboratoire
ils ont une explication qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pourquoi on les fait est que
veut dire les résultats crissement des
fois il ya des traitements qui vont
changer des trucs à ajuster des fois ça
peut être très sert donc quand tout est
bien indiquée sur l'application bessaih
beaucoup euros jusqu'ici plus de 500
patients ont utilisé opale selon un
sondage le taux d'appréciation et de 100
% et 95 % d'entre eux disent que
l'application amelia leur état de santé
nous sommes en train donc dans les 12
prochains mois d'implanter l'application
partout dans l'hôpital pour qu'un
patient qui est des problèmes cardiaques
des problèmes pulmonaires puissent aussi
avoir l'information au bout de ses
doigts
plusieurs autres centres hospitaliers
dont le chemin et sainte justine songe
également offrir l'application opale ici
norma grondin radio canada montréal